with over 300 sessions at next 2023 it's
understandable that you couldn't get to
them all so if you didn't see accelerate
cost savings with API management then
stay tuned because here's the
rewind not only can you accelerate cost
savings with your apis but you can also
improve the value you get out of your
Tech spend by driving more Innovation
and security but this needs a shift in
frame of mind to looking at apis as
products rather than simple connective
tissue or individual
technology on the business side ideally
you would be able to get your ideas into
a product and into the hands of your
users as quickly as possible and apis
play an important role in that because
that easy path isn't a straight line and
from development and scaling cost to
security considerations and your margins
that can get complicated quickly and for
the primary cost drivers of development
operational expenses and risk mitigation
expenses we've found that there are
three primary questions that are top of
mind for every customer do we have the
best infrastructure built to last are we
spending more or less on our
Technologies are we confident our data
and systems are
secure and how do apis fit into all this
apis power the majority of digital
interactions and provide an accessible
way to address these questions quickly
and API management is designed to
support you on that Journey no matter
what your business size or goals for any
use case at any scale against every
attack without having to have an entire
team of Security Experts and for every
developer even those who prefer low or
no code options and you can maximize the
value of your offering with apis even
further as they'll let you build faster
do more with less and bring peace of
mind you can get your ideas into reality
faster with the recent introduction of
duet AI in app API management you can
access duet aai using the apog plugin
available in Cloud code providing you
with an IDE experience that will help
design develop and test apis now you can
go from an idea into a spec using a
single prompt and while you're able to
move faster you can also take advantage
of fully managed runtime with built-in
controls which will help standardize on
the technology that will be helpful for
monitoring and monetizing these
apis not just building apis but with our
new product application integration you
can also use these apis to connect to
your Google cloud or thirdparty
applications without code and with
flexible pricing models tailored for
your use case you can also be sure
you're avoiding overspending regardless
of whether you're just in the evaluation
stage not quite ready to to commit or if
you have a high volume of apis and users
with more predictable costs and with the
looker Studio integration Business and
Technology leaders will be able to get
insights on your usage and analyze spend
resources and revenue with natural
language questions or dashboards freeing
up time and resources without
compromising data
intelligence security is top of mind for
every customer and with this emphasis
developers are being asked to do more
with less you need Advanced controls
with machine learning models built into
the platform like Advanced API security
to detect API misconfigurations bot
attacks and even business logic attacks
you can also act on them with guided
recommendations when considered a
product apis can help support your
ability to build for your users now and
scale as needed into the future without
having to overextend your team or your
resources
if you'd like to see the full talk check
out the link in the description and
don't forget to subscribe to our YouTube
channel for more great next rewind
content thanks for
watching